good afternoon I'm Lieutenant Jason
Johansen with the lvnpd homicide section
I'm here to provide a briefing on a
homicide investigation that we're
currently conducting at the 2700 block
of South Maryland Parkway this is
located in the area of Maryland Parkway
and Karen in the South Central Area
command and it's located in a parking
lot of a store located on the southwest
corner of that intersection
earlier this morning at approximately 9
33 a.m officers from the South Central
Area command were dispatched to a report
of a shot spot alert indicating that
there was gunshots fired in the area of
Karen and Sahara as officers were
responding to that incident a witness to
the shooting flagged down and lvmpd
motor officer who was on his motorcycle
and directed him to the scene which is
located on the South Side correction the
north side of the business
as that officer arrived he quickly uh
democated the victim who was a Hispanic
male appears to be in his 30s he
immediately requested medical
unfortunately due to the injury
sustained from the victim he was
pronounced deceased here on scene based
on that information homicide detectives
have responded and we have taken over
this investigation the information I
have is very preliminary what we know
right now is that the witness reported
that the Hispanic male victim again
who's in his 30s was involved in an
altercation which was verbal at the time
with a white male with blonde hair the
clothing descriptions have been
conflicting so I don't have a good
clothing description at that at this
time during that verbal altercation the
white male adult removed a firearm and
shot our victim and then fled into an
unknown direction to travel right now
homicide detectives are on scene we're
conducting our investigation canvassing
for additional video and we're
interviewing Witnesses at this time so
we can ascertain which direction travel
the suspect fled in and what the
altercation started over right now we do
not have what led up to the altercation
right now I urge anybody with any
information related to this
investigation to please contact Crime
Stoppers Nevada your information will
remain anonymous or to the lvnpd
homicide section as pertains to traffic
in the area right now Maryland Parkway
is wide open there is no shut down in
Maryland Parkway however Karen
is shut down between State Street and
Maryland Parkway with that I'll take any
additional questions you may have did
CVS the surveillance footage you to get
a good picture of the suspect sir right
right now the the CVS is located in that
parking lot and we are going through the
space there but it's too early to tell
what what that video shows at this time
the altercation happened in the parking
lot and not inside the business all the
indications are it happened in the
parking lot at this time
I it's always scary no matter if it
happens at night or in the daytime I I
we've had murders that have happened at
all times of day they're all nervous
weather nerve-wracking and it's
important as pertains to the
investigation and the public that lives
in a direct Community affected by it but
it is concerning it's very concerning as
we continue with our investigation thank
you would you say the Public's in any
danger with the suspect on the loose
right now based on the the details given
by the victim it does not appear that
this is random whether or not what led
up to the the incident but it does
appear there was an altercation so uh uh
at this time
I I don't have any concerns of it being
a random incident